MALE SPEAKER: So we're here back
at Devoxx, and I'm here
with Ilya Grigorik, who's here
talking about performance and
Chrome dev tools, and
performance of front
ends and web apps.
So welcome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: You were
covering two things.
First of all, in the university
session, how to
make a website's performance.
And performance is kind
of a black art, I
think, to a lot of people.
And browsers, at the
same time, are
pretty complex things.
They're almost like an OS.
So should people try to
understand how it's built, or
are there any low hanging fruits
or methodology to get
your things to--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So really,
it's both.
You should always go for the low
hanging fruit, because, by
definition, those are the
low hanging fruit.
But I think in general, if you
want to build an application
that is performant over the
long term, you need to
understand how the mechanics of
your operating system work.
And you mentioned that the
browsers are increasingly
becoming like an operating
system.
They absolutely are.
You have networking, you have
graphics, you have everything
in between.
There's literally not a computer
science problem that
we're not pushing boundaries
on in the modern browser.
That's not there.
So that was in large part what
the session was about.
Of course, you can only fit so
much into three hours, but
nonetheless it was like three
hours of here's how the
browser works.
MALE SPEAKER: And people can
find your slides online if
they Google them, I'm sure.
We'll have a link somewhere so
that people can find them.
I think they're very useful,
even with us.
And it will be on [INAUDIBLE]
as well for people to watch.
So how about things like page
speed or using CDNs or DNS
lookups is an obvious thing
people don't always look into.
These are all good things.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So these are
all techniques, right?
These are all one component
of a larger picture.
So in the web performance
community, if you will, we
kind of have this distinction,
which I don't think is
actually necessarily even fair,
which is back end versus
front end performance.
Which is like, the stuff that
happens on your server, and
then everything that
the browser does.
Whereas I like to take kind of
like a holistic picture, and
say, well, the lifetime of a
page or your app or what have
you, needs to take into
account both.
Because sometimes maybe your
app is blocked on DNS, and
then the question is,
how do I find out?
How do I measure it?
I guess kind of the other meta
point that I like to make
about performance is a lot
of people treat it
as a technical metric.
It should be a business
metric.
Performance is a feature.
There are products out there
where speed is a feature.
Think of Google search.
Speed is a feature, absolutely,
and you should
design for it as such.
So if you can connect speed
and performance to your
business or bottom
line metrics--
and in fact, I've shown a number
of case studies from
other companies outside of
Google where they see a direct
correlation between how fast
the page loads and my
conversions, or bounce rates,
and everything like that.
If you can show that to your
CEO, CFO, your team, even,
that's a viable metric, as
opposed to just being like, on
a weekend, I'm going to
spend my 20% time
optimizing the page.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, and it's
interesting to see how people
actually start using Chrome
dev tools as more like
development tools, not just the
afterthought, the tool you
bring up to fix performance
after you've built it.
So people are spending more time
in tools such as the ones
provided in Chrome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So that was kind of my second
talk, which is, the whole
premise is the browser is
probably one of the most well
instrumented platforms
that we have today.
And you may just not
realize it yet.
That was kind of the
tagline, right?
And you can do all
kinds of stuff.
You can do detail, network
debugging, look at the
graphics pipeline, look at the
low level networking, and in
fact, you have to.
Once you actually get into the
weeds of what is the browser
doing, that's what you
need to understand.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And
it is almost like
an ID at this point.
MALE SPEAKER: True, true.
I see a lot of people, a lot of
developers actually using
it as such.
So you actually looked at the
Devoxx website as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: And you have a few
things to share with our
friends organizing the
conference and
running this website.
What kind of things did you
find, and are they typical of
things you find elsewhere?
ILYA GRIGORIK: They were
actually typical, and I have
to say, the Devoxx site actually
was pretty good, all
things considered.
So no complaints there.
So some interesting takeaways.
An average page on the internet
today is about one
megabyte in size.
One meg.
I find this number surprising,
right, the first
time I heard it.
And it's composed of
over 80 requests.
So one page, where there
is 80 resources--
images, JavaScript, CSS--
that need to come in to compose
the page, and we're
connecting on average to over
30 servers to fetch all of
that data, right?
And of course, as users, we
expect all of this to happen
instantaneously.
It's like, yes, connect to 30
servers, compose all of this,
and just instantly display it.
I think for Devoxx, if memory
serves, it was more requests.
It was like 140 requests.
But nonetheless, it was
structured well, so it loaded
pretty fast.
So they did a good job.
MALE SPEAKER: So somebody must
have been using Chrome tools.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, cool.
So you also covered something
about the difference between
latency and bandwidth, and how
developers should look at it,
how it's really important.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So this is a big aha moment, I
think, for a lot of people,
where you turn on your TV, you
watch the commercials for your
ISP, and it's like, get the
latest 4G, highest speed,
whatever bandwidth connection,
right?
And oftentimes, I think, we
think of speed and performance
on the web as just bandwidth.
Like, can I get a bigger pipe,
if you will, to my house?
Because that'll solve
all problems.
If we have bigger
pages, so what?
We'll just get more bandwidth.
The problem is, bandwidth
doesn't actually help after a
certain point with
web browsing.
So as we said, we have
80 requests.
We have many parallel
connections.
And if you kind of go into lower
levels of how TCP works,
we don't actually use all the
bandwidth at the beginning of
the TCP connection.
So you're actually
bound by latency.
And unfortunately, latency
is not changing.
We have this annoying thing
called the speed of light, and
it's like, we just
can't figure out
how to go any faster.
So because of that, we need to
pay attention to latency.
This is-- you mentioned CDNs.
The whole point of a CDN is to
get a server closer to the
user, such that we
can terminate
the connection faster.
That is the prime point there.
And just understanding why you
need that is very important.
So if you're running a site
here in Europe, and your
server is in the US, because
you're using some cloud
provider, you're penalizing
all of your users by a
significant margin-- like
150, 200 milliseconds.
MALE SPEAKER: And eventually
you're not making as much
money as you should be.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, and in
all likelihood, your bounce
rates are higher, and
other things.
MALE SPEAKER: So speaking of all
of this, how much of that
is going into innovation
and standards?
I mean, I hear about HTTP2
maybe coming along.
Can you say a word about that,
and how maybe that was
inspired by [INAUDIBLE]
Google?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So actually, one of the efforts
that we've been
sponsoring at Google and working
very closely with is
the W3C web performance group.
So this is a group that was
started a couple years ago,
and it has already created a
number of standards, like
navigation timing.
Navigation timing allows you
to get instrumentation data
out of the browser for things
like, so how long did that DNS
lookup take?
You couldn't access this data
maybe even a year ago.
So we have this now, and
you mentioned HTTP2.
So that was also in some
part driven by SPDY.
So this is a kind of
experimental protocol we
deployed at Google, and it's
available in Chrome, Firefox
and Opera now.
MALE SPEAKER: Is it fair
to say that it's
used in most services?
So if you're using the Chrome
browser, and you access a
Google service, it's
actually--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
So Google servers speak SPDY.
Chrome speaks SPDY.
So if you're accessing our
service-- if you're reading
Gmail, or doing Google searches
via HTTPS, you're
running over SPDY.
You're not running over HTTP.
Now, here's a caveat.
SPDY is not a replacement
for HTTP.
HTTP is still the same,
but we kind of
changed one layer below--
basically, how we send the
messages on the wire.
And by virtue of changing that,
we can actually make the
transport more efficient, so it
can push multiple resources
over the same connection.
So the HTTP 2.0 effort is
basically that, or at least,
we have a charter now for that
working group-- the IETF
working group-- which is going
to take SPDY version two of
the protocol that we designed,
and use that
as a starting point.
So in the coming year or couple
of years, hopefully
we'll standardize it and
release it as HTTP 2.0.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Great.
That's exciting to hear.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And the world
will be a better place.
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
That's what we all aim for.
Let me close with a
final question.
What about mobile in
this whole picture?
That's probably someplace
where performance is as
important, if not more important
than desktops and
typical browsers.
You have also browsers there,
and tools are actually
available to help
you with that.
So what are we doing there?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So everything we
just talked about applies
to mobile, especially bandwidth
and latency.
So of course we still have room
for improvement in terms
of bandwidth and mobile.
Having said that, latency is
much worse than desktop, for a
number of reasons which we
won't get into here.
But it only makes it more
important that we design with
efficiency in mind, like
reusing connections,
leveraging all of the caches,
and all the rest.
We also are building--
I think we are building, but
we still need a lot better
tools for mobile.
So for example, in Chrome, we
have remote debugging, and
this is very important, not just
because you can connect
to your phone and kind of pull
the data out of it, but you
can actually simulate and use
the wireless network on your
phone to feel how the page
looks, or how it downloads, if
you will, or even
how it executes.
We develop our mobile
apps on our desktop.
We run it in an emulator, which
is still running on your
beefy quad-core with whatever
graphics card.
Then you put it on your little
phone, right, and it's still
underpowered, comparatively
speaking.
These things are getting very
good in terms of computing
power and all the rest, but
nonetheless, orders of
magnitude less.
And then it just feels very
different, right?
So with Chrome dev tools, you
can now use all the same
tooling to debug on your phone,
which is awesome.
I think we still have more room
for improvement, though.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
So looking forward to those
improvements as well.
Thanks for taking the time.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Thank you.